despite the new generation of consoles
pc remains its own unique gaming
platform that can provide experiences
you might not be able to find on other
systems while also offering a place to
play multi-platform games at their best
pcs seemingly infinite backlog of games
makes it a beast of a platform so here
are the biggest pc games to look forward
to in 2022 and beyond
rocksteady helped create one of the
all-time great superhero franchises with
batman arkham asylum and its sequels and
now it's returning to the world with a
take on the anti-hero troop suicide
squad with kill the justice league the
game centers around the four title
characters captain boomerang deadshot
harley quinn and king shark all taking
on brainwashed superheroes like superman
and the flash it's set in the same
universe as the arkham games but takes
place in metropolis instead so we'll get
a very different view of the world
rocksteady created
ghost wire tokyo is a bit different from
what we've come to expect from developer
shinji mikami and tango gameworks after
two entries in the evil within it seems
the studio is still going for a
supernatural concept but now in a first
person game with a more stylized action
focus spirits haunt tokyo and you'll
have to fight them with what's described
as karate meets magic
similar to diablo 4 blizzard's
anticipated sequel to overwatch comes
amid some tumult at the studio various
studio leads and developers have been
exiting blizzard including overwatch
head jeff kaplan and the studio has been
rocked by allegations of a toxic culture
meanwhile updates to the original
overwatch have essentially stalled as
the studio puts all its efforts towards
overwatch 2. but it was pushed out of
the 2022 fiscal year like diablo that
means we may not get to play it until
april 2023 at the earliest but in this
case we at least know we'll see it
before then the overwatch league the
official esports league based around the
game will start using overwatch 2 in its
competitions starting in spring 2022
after reaching the apex of silliness in
the original saints row series volition
is hitting the reset button for its next
open world crime game this time your
gang of young wannabe thugs occupied the
city of santo ilesso looking to make a
name for themselves in the criminal
underworld as always you'll be the boss
the create your own crime lord that
oversees a cast of wild characters after
originally targeting a february release
it was pushed back to august 23 2022
it seems dying like two has been in
conversations about anticipated games
each year since its reveal at e3 2018
and after repeated delays here we are
again while it's still intended to bring
that first person action and parkour
experience from the previous game dying
light 2 is also said to have a bigger
narrative focus that will dynamically
impact the state of the game's world and
cast of supporting characters
prince of persia the sans of time first
came out in 2003 and turned the series
into a 3d action platformer in a way it
also established the framework for
parkour gameplay elements we've seen
throughout ubisoft's games since then
after four years of post-launch support
for diablo 3 blizzard is finally putting
out a proper sequel with diablo 4 but
it's been a long time coming and it may
be longer still the studio known for its
polish it until its perfect approach has
hesitated to put a date on diablo 4 and
so far has only shown off small snippets
of the development process as it keeps
fans informed of its progress now the
studio is dealing with ongoing legal
action that has led to some creative
departures which could impact
development still previously planned for
2022 it has been pushed back meaning we
won't see it until at least april 2023
that's still a long time to wait but we
could also at least start to see more of
the game shaping up as we get closer to
its release
all we know about the elder scrolls 6 is
that it's real and that it's being
worked on we've got a short teaser
trailer with a title and that's pretty
much it here we are patiently waiting
maybe we'll get another skyrim remaster
for next gen consoles and pc in the
meantime
[Music]
announced at the game awards 2020 the
upcoming entry in the fan favorite
series still seems to be early in
development with bioware once again at
the helm with only a teaser to go by
very little is known about the game
many speculate that it may more directly
tie into the original trilogy than
continue from where mass effect
andromeda left off no release date has
been confirmed but if it's anything like
the dragon age game in development then
it's still likely a while out
the lego star wars games always seem to
hit a nice spot of light-hearted fun
while retelling the events of this star
wars universe however the skywalker saga
will capture the events from all nine
mainline movies which seems wildly
ambitious especially because this isn't
a remaster of the previous lego star
wars games that covered episodes 1
through 6. it's set to launch in spring
2021 on all major platforms
[Music]
one of the big hitters in development at
bethesda is starfield which seems to be
a sci-fi space-themed take on the
studio's rpgs not much if anything is
known about starfield gameplay-wise
other than it's said to have a major
game engine overhaul todd howard has
spoken about it in vague terms 2 and
mentioned that we will see it before we
see the elder scrolls 6.
after proving its rpg metal with the
divinity original sin games larian
studios is making a true and proper
sequel to the series that inspired it
baldur's gate 3 takes notes from both
the classic baldur's gate games and the
divinity franchise an early access
version was released in 2020 and despite
some rough spots it showed a great deal
of promise it's currently slated for a
full release in 2022
one of the games the developer obsidian
entertainment has up its sleeve is
avowed and it's intriguing considering
the studio's track record including
fallout new vegas and the outer worlds
avowd looks to be the first big rpg from
obsidian under the xbox game studios
umbrella but all we know so far comes
from the short teaser trailer shown off
during the xbox showcase from july 2020
which revealed it as a new first person
fantasy rpg set in the pillars of
eternity universe
folks keep asking where is eldon ring
but nobody stops to ask how is eldon
ring hi from software may we please get
a crumb of the ring of eld if you don't
know elden ring is the upcoming action
rpg from the soulsborne creators but
it's set in an original fantasy world
co-created by a song of ice and fire
author george r.r martin now we finally
got our hands on eldon ring which has
made the wait for february 25th 2022
even harder
[Music]
one of the most revered first-person
shooters of all time is getting a remake
in 2022 system shock was a major
inspiration for later hits like bioshock
and after a successful kickstarter
campaign night dive studios is bringing
it back what originally began as a
remaster has morphed into a full-on
reboot an early alpha version was
released in may 2020 and now the wait is
on for more details night dive has run
into development troubles related to the
pandemic and other factors but the game
is set to be coming in 2022
at this point star citizen is most
famous for raising an incredible amount
of money after ending its kickstarter
campaign in 2012 developer cloud
imperium continued raising money through
crowdfunding and releasing purchasable
modules that are said to eventually be
operable within the game itself
currently it looks like they've raised
around 400 million dollars with no
official release date for the final
product although some playable slices
have been available the uncertainty
around the release has made it a hotbed
of controversy it's most certainly not
coming in 2022 but as an ongoing project
that could make a big splash when or if
it materializes lots of people are
looking forward to their virtual voyage
among the stars
there is very little we know about the
new fable right now but at least we know
it's real its reveal concluded the xbox
showcase back in july 2020 and confirmed
that developer playground games is
behind the project
fable is an rpg series known for its
take on choice and consequence and how
they affect the way your character looks
grows and is perceived in the game world
it's exciting to think about what fable
could be in this new generation
[Music]
four spoken or as it was previously
known as project atheia is a new fantasy
action game from square enix with a fish
out of water story at its core a regular
girl from our world is pulled into a
fantastical setting complete with
dragons and in doing so she gains her
own supernatural abilities to ward off
evil
vampire the masquerade bloodlines 2 is
such a fascinating concept considering
the cult status of the original games
from between 2000 and 2004. it's a first
person rpg set in the same world of
darkness universe as its tabletop rpg
source material but in a modern-day
seattle and it looks to build on what
the bloodlines did in 2004
everwild is a brand new ip from rare and
it looks to be an adventurous game set
in an expansive outdoors with a stunning
art style while we don't know exactly
what to expect from everwild it seems
like a marriage between the natural and
supernatural world with interactions
revolving around wildlife and your party
of four which is teased in its reveal
trailer
who's going to protect gotham city
without batman around batgirl nightwing
red hood and robin of course and in an
open world action rpg called gotham
knights no less the game can be played
solo or in two-player co-op with what's
said to be a seamless drop in and out
system the story will be separate from
the existing batman arkham series though
gotham night's main story will be about
the rise of the bat family following
batman's apparent death and their
conflict with the gotham city rogues
gallery which includes the infamous
court of owls
scorn is an xbox series x and s and pc
exclusive and looks like a grotesque
horror first person shooter we got to
see some gameplay and its environments
are a mix of gothic structures inside of
a monster's body with mutant flesh
hanging on the walls and creatures used
as tools for environmental puzzles huge
hr giga vibes
kerbal space program was memorable for
its complex physics that helped show a
whole new generation how going into
space is actually really extremely hard
countless kerbals have been lost in the
attempt to construct a perfect rocket
and the sequel looks to be even more
ambitious with a focus on interstellar
travel you'll be able to cross galaxies
make colonies and play with fellow
kerbal enthusiasts in multiplayer
i'm not sure who wanted a lord of the
rings game starring gollum but we'll
give it a chance of course if you check
the steam page the release date is
marked as lurking until the time is
right we respect that
[Music]
blackbird interactive and gearbox
publishing are partnering for a third
installment in this decades-old series
this revival of the homeworld franchise
is markedly more connected to fan
feedback than most as a crowd-funded
campaign the studio invited surveys from
backers on what elements or aspects of
the original homeworld games were most
important to them the project includes
key personnel from the original
development studio as well as leadership
from the gearbox published homeworld
desert of carrick it's due out in late
2022
rainbow six siege has become a
successful live service and esport game
for ubisoft but this pve spin-off takes
a different approach instead of
competing with other players to control
an environment the co-op game has you
team up with other rainbow operators to
take down parasitic alien monsters first
revealed in 2019 this one has been
pushed back a few times perhaps in part
to avoid the unfortunately timed
associations of its original name
quarantine with the global coronavirus
pandemic it appears to be back on track
now and aiming for a release on january
22nd 2022
[Music]
one of a few games centered around super
powered multiplayer heroes taking on
hordes of monsters redfall catches our
attention based heavily on the pedigree
arcane the developer behind dishonored
prey and death loop certainly knows how
to make games that relish in granting
you superpowers so having those skills
put toward a cooperative game make it
one to watch
[Music]
senua's saga hellblade 2 continues the
harrowing journey of the titular
protagonist that started in hellblade
senua's sacrifice although we don't know
too much about this sequel it was
revealed alongside the xbox series x in
2019 with a cinematic trailer and most
recently was shown off again at the game
awards it's one of the major upcoming
games from ninja theory which is now
under the xbox game studios umbrella
monster hunter world helped the series
explode in popularity in the west but it
was difficult to tell how monster hunter
rise would translate that to the
nintendo switch when it was released in
march 2021 rise turned out to be a great
success with a good blend of classic
elements and new ones like the wire bug
now it's coming to the pc on january 12
2022 giving pc hunters a treat right at
the start of the year that will also lay
the groundwork for the sun break
expansion planned for release on both
platforms simultaneously sometime
mid-year
the world war ii real-time strategy
series company of heroes is coming back
after a long hiatus this time the game
will focus on the italian and north
african theaters of war and includes new
features like a tactical paws that
allows you to queue up commands and
increased destructibility an alpha test
conducted in late 2021 helped prepare
tacticians for the battle to come but we
don't expect to see the full game
released until late 2022
stalker 2 has been slowly teased at
first in 2018 with just a website that
had 2021 below the title and most
recently with a cinematic trailer during
the xbox showcase much like the rest of
the series stalker 2 takes place in the
nuclear exclusion zone or the zone in a
radiated chernobyl but supernatural
elements lurk about to create a
horror-like atmosphere it's said to have
one of the biggest open worlds ever in
games which sounds pretty daunting to
explore and ambitious for the first
person action franchise
the creative assembly has built up a
reputation for itself with top tier
expertise in real-time strategy that
makes its return to the warhammer
universe with total war warhammer 3 an
exciting treat for fans who've been
waiting for a proper sequel since 2017.
as usual for the total war franchise
you'll have to engage in careful
diplomacy and all-out battle to navigate
the campaign it's coming on february 17
2022
the management sim two point hospital
gets a college-bound sequel next year
two-point campus has you managing a
university campus which means overseeing
everything from housing and dormitories
to organizing classes and
extracurricular activities and hiring
staff the sim appears to take the same
wacky approach as its previous game
which means you can make the clown
college of your dreams
[Music]
there are obviously many many more pc
games launching in 2022 and beyond and
we'll always have the latest so to stay
up to date make sure you subscribe to
gamespot thanks for watching